5 26 on your wednesday morning we're
pushing the button on that hot button
traffic issue of hov lanes now instead
of talking about whether they're good or
bad nevada department of transportation
wants to learn more about them so
starting sunday scheduled to run through
early august traffic data sensors are
going to be put in at 17 freeway
locations counting vehicles and the
number of people inside them now up on
the 95 they're going to start at that
weird hov ramp at elkhorn then go south
to cheyenne a few more locations on the
95 between the rainbow curve and the
spaghetti bowl on i-15 they're putting
in sensors between charleston and spring
mountain and then again down at blue
diamond but don't expect immediate
results we're told this is a multi-year
study and now while current hov lanes
are posted as 24 hours a day enforcement
new data could be used in a pilot
program to validate the hours of
operation all the installation work
scheduled for the overnight hours to
minimize disruptions and has a detailed
schedule of all the locations in the
closures we've got those links on the
online version of the story on our
website when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put on the phone
someone driving to crazy email me
traffic eight at eight newsnow dot com